senior foreign affairs correspondent and
face nation moderator Margaret Brennan
is with us from Washington Margaret good
morning you've seen of course what the
State Department has said do you think
they'll be further retaliation yes the
UK and the United States insists that
the expulsion of these Russian nationals
is not the only kind of retaliation
they're talking about sanctions are
talking about travel restrictions and
even cyber actions and all of this sort
of unified response seemed to have taken
Moscow by surprise because in the past
you haven't seen all of these Western
countries move in solidarity to kick out
these so-called diplomats
senior UK official I spoke with said
that this chemical attack is part of an
assassination program that was
authorized by Vladimir Putin and that is
why you were seeing such a strong
response Margaret what sort of impact
will this move by Russia have on US
operations in Russia well practically
speaking the State Department says it's
going to force the layoffs of local
hires local staff it's gonna slow down
operations so it might take longer to
get a visa approved but it's also going
to impact the number of Americans who
are able to work under diplomatic cover
so it'll have some impact on our
espionage activity but remember there
were already more than 700 staff that
have been cut over the past six months
due to past Russian caps on our
personnel in that country so there
already have been those impacts and now
the Trump administration is emphasizing
that it's its own decision this week to
kick out 60 Russians is far more
significant because they say the FBI
identified these particular individuals
as undeclared Russian intelligence
efforts so they think they're kicking
out a covert Network
well it's been reported Margaret as you
know that Donald Trump said to Vladimir
Putin listen if you want to arms race we
can go there what's the state of the
relationship between these two well look
the phone calls may be friendly and
congratulatory but the foreign policy is
anything but and that recent ICBM test
that you were just showing pictures of
emphasizes where we are in the
relationship the US has been accusing
Russia going back to the Obama
of cheating on nuclear arms-control
agreements specifically this treaty
called the INF treaty basically
developing these kind of missiles that
they had promised not to do and in in
response the Trump administration says
they're gonna start researching these
kind of missile development as well
breaking out of that sort of cap we had
on the nuclear arms race but when you
look at the national security team of
the trump administration they constantly
signal to our allies around the world
don't listen so much to what the
president saying look at what we're
doing and that's pretty significant to
have national security officials say
something like that look at what we're
doing in Ukraine look at what we're
doing with these expulsion don't worry
about the friendly phone calls all right
Margaret thank you so much and Sunday on
Face the Nation Margaret will talk with
Republican senator Tim Scott Republican
congressman trey Gowdy former Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
and the UN High Commissioner for
Refugees all of that on Face the Nation
Sunday here on CBS